hello I'm
a senior writer at real clear
investigation
Washington DC and a few years ago I had
the privilege of being a visiting
Pulliam fellow in journalism at
Hillsdale College so I am very familiar
with the institution and pleased to be
here today um to start I'd like to thank
everyone in for joining us today I know
there are lots of friends in the
Hillsdale community that I'd love to
catch up with in person but we'll have
to resume the pleasantries at some point
in the future speaking for myself I hope
that comes at a time when I've been able
to visit a barber with more regularity
than I have been in recent weeks I've
prepared some remarks a day dealing with
our public health agencies and our lack
of preparedness to fight the corona
virus pandemic there's a lot to be said
about this topic but first I think
something needs to be said and that is
this so far there's not a lot of
evidence that the US was especially
ill-prepared for the corona virus there
have been a number of mistakes and had a
better course of action been settled on
in an earlier date it's very possible
that a great many of the 40,000
Americans who have died of corona virus
to date might have been saved we need to
take stock of those mistakes and I plan
on doing some of that today
however the dominant media narrative
here in the US would have you believe
that the United States was grossly
unprepared and as a result the disease
has ravaged the United States in a
uniquely disastrous way earlier this
week the Atlantic published an essay by
National Book Award winner George Packer
headlined we are living in a failed
state the corona virus didn't break
America it revealed what was already
broken
I certainly think our handling of the
pandemic continues to necessitate
caution but it's worth pointing out that
once you discard the misleading top-line
numbers the media like to dwell on
Belgium France Spain Italy the United
Kingdom Switzerland and everyone's
favorite socialist paradise Sweden have
all had more per capita deaths as a
result of the corona virus in the United
States and if you account for the fact
that nearly half of the deaths in the US
have occurred in a few square miles in
New York City where the disease was
aided by unusual population density as
well as the clearly disastrous decision
by local authorities to keep the subways
running the u.s. death toll would be
very significantly
or despite performing worse than the US
on perhaps the key coronavirus metric
would anyone in their right mind think
of Sweden and Switzerland and having
been exposed as failed States the US has
far-out performs is also far
outperformed the Doomsday metrics
regularly turned out by scientists in
the last month or so others more
informed than I will have more to say
about the problem of statistical
modeling but it's worth remembering the
line from famous statistician George box
all models are wrong but some are useful
clearly at this point we have no clear
idea what models are useful in this
instance but that hasn't stopped people
from seizing on models which in some
cases are already demonstrably wrong to
push a preferred innate narrative that
the US was singularly
unprepared indeed the discussion
surrounding the coronavirus responds to
the extent that such a discussion is
determined by media gatekeepers and
political elites has been largely driven
by narratives and not facts facts are
messy incomplete and don't always
present themselves in ways that make
patterns it's easily identifiable
narratives are malleable and they don't
have to be true to serve their intended
purpose narratives are also convenient
vehicles for affecting elections and
wielding political power as such a
shocking number of articles in recent
weeks making deeply negative and
pessimistic assertions about the
coronavirus response as such as the
aforementioned George Packer article are
thinly veiled anti-trump screeds
when they are veiled at all perhaps
tellingly very little of that pessimism
is reserved for decrying the
government's response to the massive
economic toll of the pandemic which
tells you something about how culturally
insulated the chattering classes is
never mind that the media can't seem to
summon anything from their vast reserves
of outrage when the response to a crisis
might be impeded by Democratic Party
politicking as has been the case
multiple times in recent weeks with
Democrats obstructing legislative relief
packages but once you've cast aside the
press's monomaniacal obsession with the
president you start to see more useful
analysis and perspectives on this crisis
for instance
it is absurd to declare that the US is a
failed state however in many respects
this crisis has exposed our bloated and
inefficient government as a failed
administrative state in case you were
unfamiliar administrative state is the
political science term used to describe
the vast federal bureaucracy that sprung
up in the last century or so unelected
bureaucrats now have unprecedented
authority to create and enforce so much
regulatory power that many scholars and
elected leaders rightly worry that it's
a threat to American democracy and
constitutional order and as this crisis
shows because federal agencies have
assumed so much responsibility with no
democratic accountability they cannot be
depended upon to protect Americans when
it matters most for weeks now we've seen
reporting on critical errors by federal
agencies far removed from the White
House but there has been virtually no
sustained effort to show how excessive
regulation and bureaucratic errors have
shown that big government can be deadly
one of the biggest and ongoing
government failures in response to the
pandemic has been the inability to get
large-scale diagnostic testing off the
ground some of those limitations are
technological we still don't have
reliable testing without the need for
health care professionals to administer
the test but so far the biggest
hindrance has been the federal
bureaucracy back in late January dr.
Helen Chu an infectious disease expert
in Seattle was doing research on the flu
and became worried as the first cases of
corona virus started arriving in America
she and her team were doing already
doing research on the flu and they were
in a position to quickly repurpose the
tests they were doing to detect the
corona virus the problem was that she
needed federal approval to start testing
for the corona virus and repeatedly got
shut down after weeks and trying and
failing to get federal approval to test
on her own On February 25th
dr. chu did what any heroic American
would have done in her circumstances she
started breaking the law according to
new york times dr. chu soon identified a
local teenager who had both a virus and
no recent travel history confirming
fears that the vie
that established itself in the region
and and had undoubtedly affected
countless others Seattle soon turned
into a coronavirus hot spot had dr. chu
quickly been given approval instead of
being forced to a wait until her
conscience got the better of her she
might have saved lives and establishing
the presence of a corona virus outbreak
in a major urban center weeks earlier
might have had national implications in
terms of accelerating the local and
federal containment strategies of course
this was not an isolated incident the
CDC and FDA initially declined to
certify tests that were being produced
by private companies companies whose
resources and capacity put them in a far
better position to get mass testing off
the ground and the federal government
instead they followed the government
followed their own protocols and worked
to develop their own tests and an email
dated February 26 obtained by The Wall
Street Journal the Centers for Disease
Control was telling state and local
officials quote testing capacity is more
than adequate to meet current testing
demands by mid-march the results of
government testing efforts were obvious
The Wall Street Journal headline in
March 19th was America needed
coronavirus tests the government failed
those specific failures are too detailed
and numerous to recount here but many of
the initial tests the CDC produced were
faulty and had to be recalled and all
tests were done and all the tests that
were done had to inefficiently be sent
to CDC headquarters in Atlanta to be
tested and contrary to the CDC's claims
that they had adequate testing capacity
the limited number of government
sanctioned tests available meant to CDC
implemented very narrow criteria for who
could be tested the only way you could
get a test early on was if you had
traveled to China or it could prove that
you had been in contact with someone who
had already tested positive for the
virus even now we're still learning the
extent of the CDC's testing failures
just this past weekend The Washington
Post reported the CDC reported that CDC
testing failures were also the result of
a major contamination problem that
occurred at CDC facilities where they
were assembling the test kits to send
out across the country according to the
post they see
see quote violated sound manufacturing
processes and was responsible for quote
a glaring scientific breakdown which
brings us to another issue where the
government appears to have botched the
response as the crisis began heating up
in March a dominant story was the lack
of ventilators and quote personal
protective equipment and sometimes known
as PPE for health care workers the media
coverage of this was unhelpfully focused
on the drama of state governors
demanding the federal government conjure
these items out of thin air and the
Trump administration's reaction to those
blunt demands there was far less
reporting on why the federal government
didn't have these items stockpiled and
ready to distribute in case of an
emergency an op-ed by professors Charles
silver and David a Hyman the co-authors
have overcharged why Americans pay too
much for health care gives an eyebrow
raising explanation for our lack of
ventilators in 2006 the Bush
administration wisely decided to make
preparations for a pin tent for a
potential pandemic of exactly this sort
in fact it appears President Bush
himself had read up on the subject of
pandemics and to some extent personally
directed these efforts which as of
latest were led to a strange new respect
for a man the media spent most of their
presidency trying to undermine either
way Bush's personal involvement is worth
highlighting because as we shall see
it's an example of how unelected
bureaucracy fails us even when our
elected leadership which is supposed to
be in charge does the right thing anyway
back in the Bush administration the
federal government determined that in
case of a national pandemic the country
would need some 70,000 ventilators to be
kept in a strategic national stockpile
for an event just like the one we're
currently experiencing the Department of
Health and Human Services didn't get
around to acting on this directive for
four years and in 2010 the HHS
contracted with a small relatively
unknown manufacturer Newport medical
instruments to build tens of thousands
of inexpensive portable ventilators
before production on the ventilators
began Newport medical instruments was
bought out by a larger company
the new owners backed out of the
contract with the Department of Health
and Human Services and the government
finally got around
new contract for the ventilators last
year when it was far too late to do much
good
of course now federal agencies are
finally taking care of the problem all
it took was 14 years and 40,000 dead
Americans to get them to act on it now
when it comes to PPE such as n95 masks
the health care workers need to filter
out viruses our present shortage is a
similar Taylor of incompetence in this
case the problem is even more
inexcusable because the need for masks
should have been more obvious and more
acute than the need for ventilators the
swine flu outbreak in 2009 resulted in a
two to three year backlog of orders for
n95 masks so the federal government
started distributing its own supply of
the masks to health care workers
eventually distributing about 75% of the
strategic national stockpile the same
bush-era initiative that demanded
stockpiling ventilators but according to
bloomberg news reporting it appears that
after the strategic national stockpile
of n95 masks was depleted in 2009 it was
never replenished this is even more
unforgiveable than a ventilator shortage
as n95 master used to address a wide
array of public health threats and there
was a pandemic in recent memory where
there was heavy demand for them the
failure to have the masks on hand is
simply inexcusable further the masked
shortage had a potentially deadly
deathly side effect for ordinary
citizens after weeks of federal guidance
saying American citizens did not need to
protect themselves by wearing masks in
public health recommendations changed
dramatically weeks after other Western
countries started encouraging citizens
to wear masks in public federal and
local governance started telling
Americans to wear masks as well masks do
seem to be effective at stopping the
spread of the corona virus but it
appears Americans were discouraged from
wearing masks at least in part to stop
ordinary citizens from hoarding masks
that were otherwise needed by health
care workers if federal neglect hadn't
resulted in a massive shortage at the
outset of the current crisis perhaps the
guidance on masks could have been issued
weeks earlier and the outbreak in the US
would have been much better contained
perhaps the shortest should seem like an
unfortunate anomaly but anecdotes like
this are hardly unique in Washington on
average the federal procurement process
takes anywhere from 18 months to two
years there's
no getting around the fact our federal
agencies are far too unwieldy too big to
be depended upon in a national crisis
while stringent regulations on health
care supplies exists for an obvious
reason they also need to be adaptable
when lives are on the line even in late
March well after the crisis was upon us
and hospitals were filling up there were
multiple reports of pallets full of
medical supplies sitting in warehouses
on docks for a week or more because the
FDA FDA still insisted on inspecting all
medical supplies even when they came
from trusted and proven suppliers just
two days ago Maryland governor Larry
Hogan announced that his state had
purchased 500,000 coronavirus tests from
south-korea
quote I was frosted because my team was
saying the FDA approval was going to
hold it up Hogan told the New York Times
I didn't care that I didn't care and I
was going to get the tests anyway
according to the New York Times the FDA
only gave its approval for Hogan to use
the tests as the plane carrying carrying
the test was touching down in Maryland
this past weekend it beggars belief that
a dis lay today the FDA is still holding
up tests from reliable sources such as
South Korea a country that has been a
leader in efforts to fight the pandemic
finally it's worth taking a look at the
role the federal government has played
in distributing the precious few
pharmaceutical treatments we have for
viruses such as this one of the most
promising drugs is REM desert Ram des
aveer which was developed six years ago
in response to similar vile war threats
such as the West Nile virus Zika MERS
and SARS Gilead the American
pharmaceutical company had developed the
drug never bothered to get the drug
approved in the US because the FDA's
approval process is far too onerous and
expensive given the drugs limited use
had the drug been available and more
widely prescribed these past few years
we might have gained valuable insight
into potential treatments for the
current pandemic instead we're casting
about much more blindly for drugs or
cures right now again if we must insist
on comparing the u.s. failures in its
pandemic response to other countries the
few countries that have performed better
often o their superior performance to
bureaucratic competence South Korea for
instance has been
widely praised for its ability to get
large-scale testing trace programs up
and running soon after the corona virus
outbreak however this is largely due to
the country's proximity to China which
has been the source of an inordinately
large amount of historical pandemics in
fact the original scientific thinking is
that even bubonic plague originated not
in Europe but in China sometime around
600 BC because South Korea was
inordinately impacted by SARS bird flu
and other recent pandemics from China
the country's experience has led it to
dramatically streamlines public health
infrastructure and related bureaucracy
to address sudden disease outbreaks
unfortunately for Americans the ability
of our elected leaders to do anything in
the way of reforming or reshaping our
unelected federal bureaucracy is
severely limited courts have ruled
federal employees have a property right
to their jobs even President Trump a man
famous for saying you're fired
and disregarding governmental norms has
hit a brick wall his administration has
spearheaded an admirable initiative to
clean house the Department of Veterans
Affairs after that agency's wide spread
of competence led to the deaths of
several veterans unable to get medical
treatment in recent years however the
efforts to rid the agency of bad
employees has resulted in a legal morass
that has led to reinstating many VA
employees that had already been fired
some of them more than once it is in no
way shape or form an exaggeration to say
that under current laws the president of
the United States has more authority and
discretion to start a nuclear war than
to fire a significant number of federal
workers that are constitutionally under
his direct supervision if you've ever
spent time looking at the Office of
Personnel management's databases and
virtually no journalists have done this
you know that entire cabinet agencies
with tens of thousands of employees
often go years without terminating a
single employee for cause of course as a
journalist I am all in favor of holding
the leader of the free world accountable
and I think Trump's leadership certainly
hasn't been perfect in this crisis as
another president famously said the buck
stops here but we are ignoring vital
lessons from this crisis by focusing
almost exclusively on narratives that
tell the story of failed political
leader
ship at the expense of larger systemic
problems in the federal bureaucracy that
have undermine America's constitutional
order and the good governance that comes
with it to be clear there are many
valiant and competent federal workers
giving it their all right now and they
should be lauded for their efforts
I'm sure this crisis will bring about
some needed changes and reforms within
the bureaucracy at least on the narrow
question of the federal government's
ability to respond to certain kinds of
pandemics however we don't know what the
next threat to Americans safety or
national security will be and odds are
good it will be very different than the
corona virus once again will be caught
flat-footed thanks to a clergy
bureaucracy that lacks the initiative
and imagination to anticipate threats
then a retrospect should have been
obvious and preventable in the meantime
I will say that I would be shocked to
learn that if a single federal employees
fired for any number of fatal errors
regarding this national emergency and I
don't even need a computer model to make
this prediction it's just a safe bet
thank you very much
hello and welcome to the second half of
our program I'm John J Miller director
the dow journalism program here at
Hillsdale College on the campus in
Michigan and we've just listened to an
excellent presentation by Mark Hemingway
at the Kirby Center Hillsdale colleges
Kirby Center in Washington DC mark
thanks so much for joining us and
agreeing to take a few questions
glad to be here mark from the start of
this coronavirus crisis we've heard this
compared to several major events in
American history it's like Pearl Harbor
it's like 9/11 we've heard it called a
100-year event which is a reference to
the 1918 pandemic we've also heard it
called a Black Swan in other words a
kind of major unpredictable
surprise is that a useful way of
thinking about this conundrum that's a
Black Swan yeah I think so in fact
Nassim Nicholas Taleb the man who
invented Black Swan theory as it were or
at least popularized it it defines a
Black Swan event as something that is
you know you know hugely impactful and
totally unforeseen but at the same time
also easily rationalized in retrospect
and this seems to fit the exact
definition of that and in that respect
you know 100-year event also seems like
a good way of describing it as well yes
you know we didn't know when something
like this was gonna happen but human
history and you know basic common sense
would have told you that we would have
been facing a pandemic like this sooner
or later
did george w bush predicted you you
referenced this in in your remarks and i
gather that in the summer of 2005 in the
second term of his presidency he read a
book called the the great influenza by
john berry and got worried about the
problem of a pandemic and developed a
passion for ventilators
but did he predict it and maybe put us
on to the path of preparedness and and
then we fell off I don't know if he
predicted it so much as he was wise
enough to realize that this was a
prudent thing to prepare for and that
the odds of us encountering something
like this
you know high enough that the federal
government should be ready and more than
that though the calculus is such that
the amount the federal government would
invest in emergency plot supplies for
something this would be hugely impactful
relative to the you know cost of you
know stockpiling say masks and
ventilators and a few other things that
are necessary to deal with something
like this so it just seemed like an
obvious obvious thing to do you know in
fact Tebbe Troi who was a domestic
policy adviser in the Bush White House
and later an Under Secretary of Health
and Human Services under President Bush
and his administration wrote a book just
a couple of years ago called shall we
wake the president that's a history of
presidential responses to public health
and other crises that have beset this
nation in history and Teddy Troy and his
book just a few years ago was discussing
how the US was unprepared for a
potential coronavirus outbreak before
this even happened and I'm sure that
heavy wrote that in part because he was
in the Bush administration when these
discussions were happening and you know
prudent and smart people could have seen
this coming
but then bureaucracy got in the way the
failed administrative state as you
called it you gave us a good quick
definition of the the failed
administrative state and and and and the
problems that attend to it but I'm
wondering what is the alternative for us
to an administrative state don't we want
a federal government full of experts who
know things about the transmission of
disease having that kind of expertise
and then having the power to act upon it
don't we in fact want a large government
with that kind of knowledge and
expertise and ability to to defend us
yes I think we absolutely do but I also
the same time think one of the biggest
slurs that is constantly you know
directed at conservatives or people that
you know advocate you know smaller
government is that they don't believe in
any sort of government I mean the truth
is that conservatives have always you
know use the phrase limited government
for a reason
there are times exactly like the one
we're in right now that do in fact call
for a strong government response you
know that you know needs to be dictated
by the needs of the particular Christ
and we need to be flexible about that
sort of thing which is precisely the
sort of thing you can't do when everyone
is obsessively focused on what the
federal government will do even though
constitutionally police powers and other
things like that that are useful in
crises like this are directed to state
local governments we just need to be in
a situation here where yes we have a
government that is full of capabilities
and expertise but a they need to be
responsible to political leadership and
there needs to be some accountability
for when they mess up and you know this
is like you know this is obviously a
huge crisis but there were million other
small crises we've experienced in the
last hundred years that we've been
dealing with this behemoth you know in
growing federal executive agencies where
you know their response has been
inadequate and yet we keep entrusting
them with more responsibilities and it
becomes harder and harder to make them
accountable can a strong governmental
response at the federal level can it
also be a deregulatory response and I'm
thinking about an op-ed that was in The
Wall Street Journal about a week ago by
a couple of scientists at Michigan State
University and they said we've developed
a coronavirus test it works but we can't
deploy it people can't use it because
the FDA and other regulatory bodies
won't let us
so is a AG regulatory response is that
an appropriate strong governmental
response absolutely I mean I think that
that is one thing we need to be looking
at you know in this crisis you know and
I gave lots of examples I hope of where
you know federal the federal existing
federal laws got in the way at a minimum
we need to have some sort of plan for
you know what laws or regulations that
you know maybe we need to learn to
immediately suspended by some sort of
emergency declaration or things like
that so they don't get in the way of a
response but you know there needs to be
a plan to make the federal government
nimble in situations like this and as it
stands now the idea that we're holding
up medical supplies that are badly
needed while people are dying because
they can't get FDA approval or we're not
you know get doing enough testing
because you know we can't get FDA
approval like a you know again
or or we're dependent on the CDC it's
it's pure insanity and I think people
see that at the state level the good
news is we have seen some responses that
that have been very good a couple of
states have suspended licensure
requirements for doctors meaning that if
they need more doctors to address the
threats in their state because it's
become a hot spot or something like that
they're not going to be exposing doctors
to liability if they come in from other
states and aren't licensed to practice
in that state so that's a good positive
example we're seeing at levels below the
federal government and the federal
government I think needs to emulate that
sort of thing how can we judge the
success of states in our federal system
in confronting coronavirus is it just a
matter of counting up cases and deaths
and population rates and so forth and
and and judging them that way or have we
seen other kinds of strengths and
weaknesses that's a really difficult
question to answer at this point in time
I mean I think we need more dad and we
need to be out on the other side of this
to really make some definitive questions
that make some definitive conclusions
obviously you know it's gonna be a
little from column a and a little from
column B I mean obviously like I
mentioned there were certain factors
about in New York City you know in terms
of it having a population density that
is you know virtually unrivaled almost
anywhere else in the United States that
led to the corona virus outbreak at the
same time the local authorities made
some decisions regarding public transit
and keeping Subway's open and things
like that that we've now seen a lot of
evidence and retrospect seems like we're
disastrous decisions you know so you
know on one hand New York there's a lot
of what happen to your Kamat have been
unavoidable but there are definitely
things that we can point to that were
we're wrong I think in terms of some of
the responses and containment strategies
things are a little clearer
obviously in Hillsdale you know local
state of Michigan there's been some
controversy over some of the things that
the governor's done where people thought
that you know that they were being a bit
draconian where you know liquor stores
get to stay open but you know you can't
buy seeds to plant in your garden even
though you can buy you know plenty of
other supplies on the other side of the
same Home Depot store you might get
where you might need essential supplies
so you know there are
the lockdowns and containment policies I
think we're seeing some clearly bad
decisions and then we can judge that
accordingly you mentioned George Packer
in your remarks and this and this piece
he wrote for the Atlantic in which he
referred to United States as a failed
state do you think in the future maybe
in in the weeks and months ahead he'll
he'll say that New York City was a
failed state well yeah that that's a
really good question
our you know in a good example of why I
think it is dangerous to look at a
situation like this particularly without
the benefit of hindsight in some sort of
historical perspective strictly from a
political lens like I said you know
there are certainly decisions by local
authorities in New York that I might be
inclined to disagree with because I
might have my own inherent political
biases but at the same time I mean there
were also things that were out of you
know New York's control and the same is
true in in virtually every other
situation where we're seeing this you
know there's there's a little bit of
politics involved and there's a little
bit of you know X factors and biology
involved so you know it's it's just
absolutely absurd to focus in constantly
on this and you know narrative that is
entirely dependent on the fact that the
occupant of the White House is someone
you don't like and belongs to a
political party that you've never liked
mark we've talked about the federal
response also the states and and cities
and all the responses at all kinds of
levels
what about internationally and I'm
thinking about other governments like
like China and its actions and other
organ international organizations like
the World Health Organization how much
should we depend on them in the future
how much should we rely upon them or
should we just be prepared to go it
alone in problems like this well the
this is sort of the $64,000 question I
think a lot of experts are trying to
deal with right now there's absolutely
no question that the World Health
Organization failed us and specifically
failed us pretty because they were
susceptible to Chinese propaganda and
didn't want to rock the boat in terms of
dealing with FEMA the autocratic
communist Chinese government and it is
appalling that they were so easily
misled in the
that they were and there's no question
that thousands of lives were lost as a
result of the World Health
Organization's mistakes having said that
you know again it is it's it's a good
idea and it is very useful to have some
sort of international organization that
has expertise that can parachute into
countries that maybe don't have the
public health health infrastructure the
countries in need like the United States
or Western Europe have and provide
resources in them and stop public health
threats in the bud before they spread
all over the globe but you know if the
World Health Organization is going to
exist in in the future it's got to be
substantially reformed I mean a lot of
the same problems that I was talking
about with America's federal bureaucracy
obviously apply to the World Health
Organization it is very much a
bureaucracy and it very much has its own
self-interested imperative largely
because it doesn't really have any
accountability I mean it's an
international organization you know
multilateral investment it just it
doesn't have democratic accountability
and for so long has just been sort of
left to its own devices and and to act
on its own selfish interests so when
Donald Trump was talking about with
withdrawing funding from the World
Health Organization and and I would hope
that other people would follow suit at
least in terms of you know credible
threats to the agencies such that the
agency response to the criticisms and so
far months into this crisis their their
response to very valid criticisms for
obvious mistakes they made has been you
know appalling they just seemed to be
like doubling down and continuing by you
know in to a somewhat lesser degree but
nonetheless parroting Chinese propaganda
and it's a big problem
the media's played an enormous ly
important role throughout this period
everything from from telling us what's
happening to explaining what social
distancing means to helping think
through some of the problems that were
experienced you know how we might have
done better but was the media unprepared
for this crisis oh they're absolutely
unprepared for this crisis and they
continue to be unprepared for this
crisis in fact if you actually followed
the news coverage of this from the
beginning I mean at the time in January
right around the time on this
heating up and about the time the Trump
first issued the Federal directive
banning travel coming in from China
there were numerous reports in the
Washington Post and lots of other
mainstream media outlets saying that we
didn't need to worry about this we
should be more worried about the flu
there were numerous reports at the time
saying that Trump's travel ban which
definitely looks effective in retrospect
was you know racist and ineffective and
other things like that you know you had
CNN Akers saying on air through early
March that this will you know this was
comparable to the seasonal flu and and
and downplaying the threat then of
course when Trump said some things along
those lines making comparisons to the
flu and other things like that in March
the media pounced and pretended that
they had all along had this you know
laser-like focus and you know foresight
about what this threat was going to turn
into and the reality isn't many of them
acted irresponsibly and didn't grasp the
nature of the threat themselves so I
mean it's just been kind of a dog's
breakfast as far as the media coverage
is concerned and more than that though
this is a time when we need a strong and
credible media and we just don't have it
like I said they have overwhelmingly
focused you know now that the political
consequences of this look like they
could be you know very bad potentially
for the the president in the White House
we've just seen you know a tremendous
amount of doom and gloom and criticism
directed the political leadership
without taking stock of you know bigger
picture failures like systemic
bureaucracy and so many other things
I've been talking about then might
actually be useful lessons for people I
just think that the the news media needs
to step back from it's sort of you know
horse race political coverage and
examine this with an eye toward what
does the average American need to know
you know what information can we get out
there that would actually help stop
you know the virus you know invest
serious effort into determining whether
or not the scientific information that
they're constantly throwing out is
credible or reasonable I mean I would
think it's like I said it's safe to say
that a lot of the models we saw early on
were were very wrong that we're
trumpeted by the media so we just need
more sort of you know judgment and and
that's very much in short supply in the
media unfortunately mark Hemingway
thanks so much for joining us and
telling us all about US public health
agencies and their failure to prepare
for coronavirus it was my pleasure and
thanks to all of you for watching our
program